c'est que je pensais
qu’on pouvait prendre soin de sa santé,
ou s’occuper de ses obligations,
toujours l’un au détriment de l'autre.
Maintenant, après plusieurs centaines de ces réunions à pied
J'ai appris quelques petites choses.
Tout d'abord, cette chose étonnante
qui est de s’éloigner de la normalité
et de sortir des sentiers battus.
Qu'il s'agisse de la nature ou de l'exercice même, ça marche certainement.
Deuxièmement, et sans doute ce qui donne le plus à penser
c'est combien chacun d'entre nous
puisse considérer les problèmes en opposition
quand ils ne le sont pas vraiment.
Et si nous résolvons les problèmes
et regardons le monde de manière vraiment différente,
que ce soit en matière de gouvernance, entrepreneuriat,
de questions environnementales, ou de création d'emplois,
peut-être pouvons-nous réfléchir à une façon de recadrer ces problèmes
et les résoudre tous les deux en même temps.
Parce que c’est à ce moment là
avec cette idée de discuter en marchant
que les choses sont devenues faisables, durables et viables.
J'ai donc commencé ce discours en parlant des fesses,
tout ça pour dire :
marchez et discutez.
Marchez et discutez.
Vous serez surpris de voir comment l'air frais apporte des idées fraîches,
et la façon dont vous le faîtes,
apportera à votre vie de toutes nouvelles idées.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)